um die gleichheit ganz zu erreichen
müsse den frauen das duell gestartet
werden behauptete der französische
dichter stoner ob es gleich so
martialisch forderungen braucht bleibe
dahingestellt
tatsache ist dass das rollenspiel nach
wie vor oft zu ungunsten der frauen aus
fällt zb im kunstbetrieb
das jedenfalls behauptet die us
amerikanische autorin sie ihre
höchstwert die heute morgen bei mir zu
gast ist
guten morgen begrüßte die einzige person
die ich kenne die den gleichen vornamen
trägt wie sie ist eigentlich nur eine
stimme hören sie hier
es ist 11 uhr 1 kommt morgen
ich weiß nicht wo du bist aber ich kann
es herausfinden wer bin ich ja dazu
möchte ich sagen mich gibt es schon
länger als diese serie
ich bin die verkörperte version und ich
bin älter als sie das ist sicher dass
sie die verkörperte version sind
siri ist nur eine stimme auf dem iphone
nichts mehr wir lebenden menschen
hingegen sind körperliche wesen glaube
sie ist ein zufall dass das eine
frauenstimme ist die mir meine termine
mitteilt oder vielleicht auch den
wetterbericht
der grund ist zutiefst kulturell männer
akzeptieren keine anweisungen von
anderen männern an einer gewissen stelle
auch immer wieder in ihren büchern das
eigentlich sehr viel leben in diesem
rollenspiel gefangen ist wir können uns
da auch nicht so gut da raus
herausbewegen interessant ist ja dass
siri als frauenstimme die
standardeinstellung ist aber man könnte
sie auch als männerstimme einstellen auf
dem handy wenn man wollen würde aber im
kunstbetrieb sagen sie ist die
standardeinstellung
eigentlich der männliche blick es ist
komplizierter man hat immer gleichzeitig
mehrere perspektiven die einzige
perspektive gibt es nicht was ich sagen
will dass männliche ist enorm
das gilt für die ganze westliche kultur
zb spricht niemand in den usa von
männlichen künstler
niemand würde von weißen männlichen
künstlern sprechen
bei frauen hingegen fügt man das
adjektiv weiblich bei also ein
weiblicher komponist oder ein weiblicher
roman autor das zeigt sehr gut welche
kulturellen vorurteile unser verständnis
von allgemeingültigkeit prägen
interessant ist dass es im deutschen
eigentlich noch extremer ist bei man
sehr oft liest die weibliche autorin
wohingegen eigentlichen autorin die frau
ja schon in taten wäre aber sie haben ja
ein buch geschrieben ein neues buch die
gleißende welt da geht es um den
kunstbetrieb und das buch startet
relativ heftig ich muss den ersten satz
einfach vorlesen
es beginnt so dass sie schreiben alle
intellektuellen und künstlerischen
unterfangen sogar witze ironische
bemerkungen und parodien schneiden in
der meinung der menge besser ab wenn die
menge weiß dass sie hinter dem großen
werk einen schwanz und ein paar eier
ausmachen kann
das ist ein zitat aus einem werk das
angeblich von einem mann namens rip
brinkmann geschrieben wurde der diese
worte der künstlerin harriett bergen in
den mund legt sie ist die hauptperson
des romans sehr schnell finden wir
heraus dass richard brockmann in
wirklichkeit halliburton ist es ist
kompliziert das wort menge wird im zitat
absichtlich benutzt als hinweis auf
kirkegaard
und der verweis auf ironie und witz ist
ebenfalls ein fingerzeig an den leser
dass es kompliziert ist die ganze
geschichte ist ja eine geschichte
eigentlich von einem täuschungsmanöver
sohar jetzt bewerben eine alternde
künstlerin ist relativ erfolglos
geblieben in ihrem leben unter anderem
eben auch weil sie immer im schatten
stand ihres mannes und am ende ihres
lebens oder eben im alter aus der mann
gestorben ist entscheidet sie
sie will wirklich noch mal wissen und
sie lässt ihre drei oder drei große
kunstwerke von männern heraus geben sie
tut so als hätten die männer diese
kunstwerke erschaffen und schlussendlich
fliegt das täuschungsmanöver aber nicht
in einer art und weise auf ich habe
jetzt werden erhofft hat zwar werden
diese männer berühmt aber keiner glaubt
ihr dass sie die urheberin ist und habe
ich mich gefragt ist es denn unmöglich
diese geschlechterrollen zu durchbrechen
nein wir alle spielen laufend männliche
und weibliche rollen
das buch fängt damit an dass harry
burdon tod ist ein herausgeber sammelt
material über harriet würden weil sie
nach ihrem tod berühmt geworden ist
wäre das nicht der fall würde niemand
ein buch über sie herausgeben
der wissenschaftliche experte zollt
diesem künstlerischen vermächtnisses
tribut jetzt wo sie erfolg und rom nicht
mehr genießen kann
das ist ein wichtiger teil der
geschichte dass sie erst nach ihrem tod
anerkannt wird
kein seltenes schicksal von frauen aber
trotzdem ist es so dass im moment wo sie
hat nicht an sich hinstellt und ja einen
leserbrief schreibt und aufdeckt dass
sie haben nicht die urheberin dieser
kunstwerke war die eben dann so
erfolgreich sind
da gibt es eine figur die sagt nein nein
ich habe dieses kunstwerk erschaffen er
begeht dann noch suizid in spektakulärer
weise und schlussendlich glaubt man ja
wieder nicht und ein stück weit kriegt
man doch den eindruck es ist wirklich
ein gefängnis
rolle als frau als künstlerin die nicht
ernst genommen
es ist schwierig zu verstehen
aber in diesem buch geht es wirklich um
wahrnehmung nicht los um
geschlechterrollen und die identität von
mann und frau und wie sie sein sollten
sondern darum wie unsere erwartungen
unsere wahrnehmung bestimmen
eine von harrods masken ist ein
schwarzer schwuler und das werk das herz
schafft mit etwas hilfe von fineos qr
codes wird durch dessen schwarz sein und
schwulsein gelesen
[Musik]
für die betrachter ist es sehr schwierig
denn künstler von der kunst zu
entkoppeln
so ist es ironisch dass diese halb
protestantische halb jüdischer alternde
frau ein kunstwerk schafft
weil aber niemand weiß dass eine frau
dahinter steckt und wer sie ist wird es
als das werk eines schwarzen und schulen
gelesen
bei den weißen männern ist es anders
weil sie wie bereits erwähnt ins
allgemeine rollenbild passen aber das
ganze ist noch komplizierter
in dem harry hat diese drei männlichen
fassaden oder masken hervorbringt kann
sie seiten von sich selber erkunden
seiten ihre eigenen männlichkeit
dabei geht es um das abenteuer die
geografie ihre eigenen persönlichkeit zu
erforschen
die masten sind nicht nur verhüllungen
sie entlarven auch gleich wie das
griechische theater maske nicht
einsetzte um charakteren zu verstecken
sondern um sie zu offenbaren
ein stück weit auch beim punkt wie sehen
wir eigentlich nehmen wir wahr
ich habe jetzt von den masken erzählt
aber vorher in
sie auch etwas gesagt über die art und
weise wie wir sehen dass ich ein stück
weiter immerhin vorurteilen
nun kann man das ja negativ finden
vorurteile sind auch im deutschen
relativ negativ behaftet aber vorurteile
helfen uns ja auch zu sehen damit ihr
kategorien bilden können haben wir
sachen zu können
wie gehen wir mit dieser spannung was
sie sagen ist absolut wahr und brillant
formuliert wir können die welt nur
wahrnehmen durch unsere erwartungen die
wir an sie richten die aktuellen euro-
biologische forschung zeigt recht
deutlich dass wir nicht einfach passive
empfänger einer realen welt dort draußen
sind sondern dass wir die welt die wir
sehen aktiv konstruieren und kreieren
basierend auf den mustern aus unserer
vergangenheit viele dieser muster sind
so vertraut geworden und so automatisch
dass wir sie nicht mehr bewusst
wahrnehmen
ein großer teil unserer wahrnehmung wird
durch solche muster die wir der welt zu
ordnen geprägt dadurch versteht man viel
besser weshalb vorurteile und
voreingenommenheit fortbestehen in der
wahrnehmung steckt immer auch ein
konservatives bewahren das element die
konservative seite die kann ein problem
sein ein anderes problem kann sein dass
natürlich diejenigen die immer quasi
einen sozial niedrigeren stellenwert
tanzen dann keine gelegenheit haben
richtig wahrgenommen zu werden oder in
der wahrnehmung die stelle zu wechseln
und das trifft ja beispielsweise eben
auf frauen zu aber man geht es ja auch
auch da wieder das umgekehrte phänomen
nämlich die positive diskriminierung
dass man zuweilen dann sachen auswählt
weil man immer denkt unterdrückt worden
ich habe zum beispiel in ihrem buch sehr
schön gefunden was sie edith stein
erwähnen die hose schülerin eine
philosophin die ich selber sehr sehr
schätze
aber interessant daran ist doch auch
dass ich manchmal den eindruck haben wir
wählen sie aber wir sprechen über sie
gerade auch weil sie eine frau ist
also dass wir umgekehrt ich habe nicht
den eindruck dass edith stein jeden
zweiten tag erwähnt wird
ich bin eine große bewunderin ihres
buches über einfühlung sie unterscheidet
sich in wichtigen punkten von hus
es mag sein dass man philosophinnen in
gewissen momenten ins rampenlicht rückt
tatsache ist aber auch dass frauen als
philosophin vergessen werden zb in
meinem buch mark cavendish wurde nicht
völlig vergessen aber fast 300 jahre
lang hat man die kraft ihres denkens
ihre brillanten und originellen ideen
zum leib seele problem abgelehnt wie sie
sagten es geht in beide richtungen und
die ganze kunstgeschichte ich
tatsächlich eine geschichte einerseits
von frauen die man nie gesehen hat deren
werk nie berühmt wurde aber auch von
sehr sehr vielen frauen die man einfach
vergessen haben dass artemis gentle sg
beispielsweise oder die schweizerin
angelika kauffmann die zu ihrer zeit
sehr sehr berühmt waren angelika
kaufmann hat goethe gemalt
beispielsweise sind irgendwann einfach
vergessen gegangen und eine eine gruppe
die sie auch erwähnen in ihrem buch sind
die guerilla girls die mit diesem jahr
karl sind immer wieder zuzulassen was
ist das plakat von 2011 das besagt
müssten frauen eigentlich nackt sein um
ins museum ausgestellt zu werden
was ist was ist das anliegen dieser
gruppe als dieses plakat erschien waren
die verhältniszahlen schlecht so sind es
heute noch
im metropolitan museum gibt es viel
kunst aus vergangenen jahrhunderten aber
sogar in der sammlung des museum of
modern art in new york ist der
prozentsatz von künstlerinnen sehr klein
da hat sich nicht viel verbessert wie
sie sagen ich würde sogar noch weiter
gehen und sagen kunstwerke von frauen
sind oft nicht vergessen sondern werden
unterdrückt
betrachten sie die forschung zum
neunzehnten jahrhundert damals gab es
bedeutende bildende künstlerinnen aber
auch wichtige schriftstellerin die
einfach ausgelassen wurden
sie verkauften sich gut wurden
respektiert und dann sind sie
verschollen
man kann sogar die momente fest machen
in denen das geschah sie erwähnten
artemisia denn die ski ihr bestes werk
wurde ihrem vater zugeschrieben heute
weiß man dass sie die urheberin einer
reihe von werken ist deren ursprung
umstritten war bei einem wirklich guten
werk wird aber automatisch angenommen
dass es von einem mann geschaffen wurde
es stellt sich wirklich die frage
weshalb ist das so
[Musik]
ich glaube dass es einen engen
zusammenhang gibt
in der westlichen kultur natürlich gibt
es auch andere frauenfeindliche kulturen
dass wir in der westlichen kultur noch
immer männlichkeit mit intellekt
verbinden und weiblichkeit mit körper
das heißt kultur ist männlich natur ist
weiblich wir fallen weiterhin auf dieses
binäre musste herein und wenn wir uns
dessen nicht bewusst werden wird es so
weitergehen
gerade dasselbe das auch so auf dass sie
eine frau sind die eben sehr viel
intellekt immer wieder an
gelegen also gerade ich habe selber
gesagt ihre bücher sind sehr konstruiert
gerade dieser roman die gleißende welt 1
1 eine geschichte die unglaublich
konstruiert daher konnte man hat aber
auch immer das gefühl jedes detail ist
noch überlegt und passt wie ein
puzzlestein und anderen das heißt ihnen
macht was auch richtig spaß
ich hatte so großen spaß
das punkt war nicht einfach aber es war
ein vergnügen das schreiben war ein
absolutes vergnügen
es spielt auf vielen ebenen die
geschichte ist hoch emotional ich wollte
dass meine hauptperson harriet das
binäre musste erforscht von dem wir
soeben gesprochen haben sie ist enorm
belesen
gleichzeitig ist sie eine
leidenschaftliche person und sie ist
mutter diese eigenschaften gelten als
gegensätze die ich in der figur von
harriet börsen zusammen führen wollte
sie lieben kunst uns alle oder viele
viele viele bücher drehen sich auch ein
kunst ja noch als kind schon gezeichnet
sie teilen immer noch oder
ich zeichne immer noch und es bereitet
mir freude
ich habe nie damit aufgehört und ich bin
überzeugt dass man rückgriff auf
bildende künstler in den romanen damit
zu tun hat dass ich mir werke vorstellen
die ich geschaffen haben könnte wenn ich
einen anderen weg gewählt hätte sie auch
ein essay geschrieben haben in leben
denken schau in einem essay band luis
bouza ist bei uns allen bekannt geworden
in der schweiz jetzt mit dieser skulptur
die mama heißt eine gigantische spinnen
die 2011 in zürich auf dem bürkliplatz
stand gefällt ihnen die skulptur ja was
louis blues war anbelangt sie hat uns
viel erzählt sie war auch autorin
sie schrieb großartig vor allem artikel
in zeitschriften sehr interessant
auch ihre interviews vor loris bruder
ist die spinne eine mütterliche figur
die beides hat angst machende wie auch
sehr positive seite ich glaube auch sie
arbeitet mit einem symbol dem sie nicht
ausschließlich positive oder negative
eigenschaften zuordnen will die spinne
ist eine ungemein kreative kraft die
netze spinnt und lebt diese symbolik
wollte sie nutzen
ich habe dieses bild noch mitgebracht
weil es eines ihrer lieblingsbilder ist
zählen
was lieben sie daran sie sagen er im
buch es sei ein erotisches spiel aber
auch ein erotisches kultur auch
humorvoll
es ist lustig sie haben recht es ist
erotisch für mich
das ist meine persönliche interpretation
stellt es die notwendigkeit da dass sich
eine person in einer anderen entfaltet
ein thema das die westliche wissenschaft
die naturwissenschaft wie auch die
philosophiegeschichte oft vernachlässigt
haben
allen voran
wir alle wurden aus dem körper einer
frau geboren
wir alle haben von anfang an eine
nabelschnur verbindung zu einem anderen
menschen
man spricht in diesem zusammenhang von
der zweiten generation der
kognitionswissenschaft oder von der
wende zur körperlichkeit in der
philosophie und der neurowissenschaft
diese ideen gehen zurück auf den
gedanken dass zu jedem hirn ein zweites
hirn gehört dass kein einzelner mensch
ohne einen anderen sein kann dass die
vorstellung vom einsamen individuum
falsch ist genau das erzählt uns diese
wunderschöne skulptur von louise
bourgeois
staudinger dass diese körper so eng
ineinander von minuten sind sie selber
sind ja mutter einer tochter von sophie
die eine berühmte sängerin sitzt was
heißt das denn für sie mutter zu sein
ist dieses verwoben seien immer noch
sehr präsent in ihrem leben und die
tochter jetzt erwachsen
natürlich fühle nicht alle frauen so
aber ich wollte unbedingt mutter werden
das hängt zweifellos damit zusammen dass
ich meine eigenen mutter sehr nah bin
ich verehre sie sie ist jetzt 92 jahre
alt die idee von mutterschaft ist in
erster linie mit meiner eigenen mutter
verknüpft als ich meine tochter bekam
war ich nicht mehr ganz jung als sie auf
die welt kam war ich 32
das war genau der richtige moment für
mich ich genoss ihre kindheit sie
aufwachsen zu sehen und natürlich stark
involviert zu sein wie auch ihr vater
es war ein großartiges abenteuer
andererseits ist es extrem spannend
menschliche entwicklung aus der nähe zu
beobachten
ich hatte immer zwei augen zum einen war
ich leidenschaftliche mutter zum anderen
konnte ich sprach entwicklung beobachten
motorische entwicklung beobachten
das ist außergewöhnlich abspult sprechen
wir mal nicht über ihre mutter sein
vater weil ich finde da gibt es ja auch
eine parallele zu louis bursch war luis
bouza hatte eine schwierige beziehung
mit ihrem vater sie lachen
mein vater war wie viele männer seiner
generation eine art distanzierter vater
das war manchmal schmerzlich louis schuf
eine skulptur mit dem namen die
zerstörung des vaters
die geschichte die sie dazu erzählt ist
dass es sich um ein mythologisches werk
handle
sie und ihr bruder sein als kinder so
wütend auf ihren vater gewesen dass sie
ihn zerstückelt und gegessen hätten
eine solch gewalttätige beziehung hatte
ich nicht zu meinem vater er liebte mich
und war sehr stolz auf mich aber es ist
keine frage dass die traditionelle
distanz das trifft sowohl auf den
europäischen wie auf den amerikanischen
vater der 1950 er jahre zu der zur
arbeit gehen und heimkam
während viele mütter damals mit den
kindern daheim blieben
dieses muster wenn sie so wollen
schließt väter von jener arzt der
vertrautheit aus die kindern
wahrscheinlich gut tut
im laufe meines lebens hat sich in
dieser hinsicht einiges verändert in
brooklyn trifft man ständig auf väter
die ihre babys ins nachließ herumtragen
als ich ein kind war gab es das nicht
man sah nie einen mann der einen
kinderwagen geschoben hätte das galt als
unmännlich die tochter von norwegischen
einwanderern sind selber minnesota
aufgewachsen irgendwo habe ich gelesen
ihr vater hätte auch unter einem
kriegstrauma geliebten weil er selber
als soldat gekämpft hat ich nutzte die
geschichte meines vaters von den
philippinen im buch die leiden eines
amerikaners vor seinem tod schrieb mein
vater seine memoiren die er seiner
familie und seinen freunden hinterließ
darin erzählt er die dramatische episode
einer autofahrt auf den philippinen bei
der sie plötzlich einen japanischen
offizier im gras liegen sahen
[Musik]
sie hielten den lastwagen an
mein vater war zusammen mit einem
vorgesetzten offizier unterwegs und
erwartete dass sie nun einen gefangenen
machen will
stattdessen erschoss der vorgesetzte
meines vaters den mann
das war ein furchtbares erlebnis mein
vater war schon in der schlacht um die
sonne auf den philippinen dabei er hatte
viele tote und viel blutvergießen
gesehen
er protestierte und wurde ruhig gestellt
später holte ihn das bild des sterbenden
japanischen offiziers wieder ein
in flashbacks meist in der nacht er
schrieb darüber in den memoiren die er
uns gab
er hatte also fleischwerks meist in der
nacht einmal tagsüber ich verwendete die
memoiren meines vaters direkt in einer
passage in die leiden eines amerikaners
hinten im buch weise ich darauf hin
ich tu nicht so als hätte ich diese
episoden erfunden sie gehen wirklich
direkt auf meinen vater zurück aber auch
sagt dass sie eine respektsperson für
sie beschreiben in einem porträt film
den es gibt vom wdr über sie wie sie
unglaublich weinen mussten aus ihr vater
ihren roman gelesen hat was ich liebte
der ihnen damals zum durchbruch
verholfen hat und sie konnten gar nicht
mehr aufhören weil er so begeistert war
von diesem buch haben sie den us tochter
immer auch nach anerkennung gelegt
in einem meiner essays mit dem titel
mein vater ich sage ich ganz klar dass
ich bei diesem ausbruch die an gestorben
tränen vieler jahre weinte es war nicht
so dass ich die ganze zeit geweint hätte
doch ich wusste nicht dass ich so
reagieren würde
aber die zurückhaltung meines vaters
gegenüber meiner arbeit
die tatsache dass er mit mir kaum
darüber sprach war natürlich eine
enttäuschung als er spät in seinem leben
mit so leidenschaftlich im enthusiasmus
reagierte war das gut
nicht nur für mich übrigens es tat uns
beiden gut drei jahre nach dem tod ihres
vaters hätten sie an einer gedenkfeier
eine rede halten sollen und sie begannen
ganz stark zu zittern sie hatten eine
form von geismar nicht recht was man bis
heute nicht recht epilepsie und dieses
phänomen des zitterns hat sie immer
wieder heimgesucht und sie haben genau
darüber dann eben auch ein buch
geschrieben das heißt die zitternde frau
und es ist ein es sei da machen sie sich
auf die suche nach den spuren dieser
neurologischen attacken die sie da haben
haben die solche anfälle bis heute
nein diese symptome trat nur viermal auf
es war kein fortdauerndes drama alle
vier vorkommnisse sind im buch erwähnt
was mich daran fasziniert war dass es
sich um ein symptom handelte das sich
aus verschiedenen blickwinkeln
erforschen wollte der ursprung des buchs
geht auf eine anfrage der columbia
medical school zurück die mich für eine
vorlesung eingeladen hatte bevor ich zum
ersten mal einen solchen zither anfang
hatte plötzlich dachte ich das
wäre interessant ich nehme mein eigenes
symptom und betrachte es durch die
linsen der psychoanalyse der psychiatrie
und der neurowissenschaft und schaue was
passiert das war der auslöser für das
buch bei genauem hinschauen sieht man
dass sich nur gerade zehn prozent um
meine geschichte drehen 90 prozent
widmen sich der erforschung des symptoms
und dem versuch das leib seele problem
zu verstehen was ist ein
psychosomatische symptome und wie sollen
wir über so etwas denken es gibt keine
sichere diagnose dafür meine neurologin
las das buch
es gefiel ihr und sie sagte wir sind uns
einig dass wir nicht wirklich wissen was
es ist meine eigene vermutung ist dass
es sich um eine mischung von
neurologischer veranlagung handelt ich
leide unter migräne und peripherer
neuropathie ich bin also eine person
deren nervensystem schon seit langem und
stabil ist seit meiner kindheit
das hat mich wahrscheinlich empfänglich
gemacht für diese art von symptom und
dann gibt es oft einen emotionalen
auslöser und dieser zusammenspiel
zwischen leib und seele wenn das leib
seele problem ein altes problem in der
philosophie
das interessiert ja schon sehr lange sie
sind mittlerweile auch eine gefragte
rednerin und psychiatrie kongressen
bewegen sich an dieser schnittstelle
zwischen wissenschaft literatur
philosophie auch zum beispiel was ich
liebte habe ich viel gelernt über das
phänomen der history die geschichte der
historie aber interessant ist ja immer
auch dass es immer wieder auch kritiken
gab kritik gab die gesagt haben
der höchstwert ist dann am besten wenn
sie essays schreibt und jemand der es
auch sehr sehr liebt ist ein freund von
ihnen
salman rushdie und wir sehen uns sagen
was er zu ihren essays sagt aus einem
filmporträt über sie ich halte sie rief
eine seltene erscheinung in amerika eine
intellektuelle vom alten schlag die es
früher öfter gab wie susan sontag
sie hat diese emotionale intelligenz es
geht nicht nur um ihren geist oder
komplexe ideen
sie hat einen besonderen zugang zu
komplexen gefühlen
es gibt wenige schriftsteller die so
emotional intelligent sind wie sie es
ist ein sehr schöner kommentar es war
während der fahrt war mein mann und ich
waren große fans von salman
so trafen wir uns eigenartigerweise
nicht in erster linie aus politischen
gründen
wir beide hatten sein werk gelesen aber
unsere aktive und lautstarke
unterstützung für ihn und seine
standpunkte brachte uns zusammen
seither sind wir befreundet er spricht
von ihrer emotionalen intelligenz ich
habe mich gefragt gibt es überhaupt sagt
was sie emotionale intelligenz das ist
ja schon wieder so eine separierung es
gibt sozusagen die analytische
intelligenz und die emotionale
intelligenz
ich denke soll man wollte darauf
hinweisen dass ich viel weiß und über
analytische intelligenz verfüge aber
dass da auch gefühle hineinspielen
es gibt trockene schreiber jeder hat
schon trockene werke gelesen die
jegliche leidenschaft entbehren die
besten philosophischen wie auch
literarischen werke sind aber immer auch
leidenschaftliche werke das interessante
daran ist wir erinnern uns durch gefühle
wir sind neurobiologisch so codiert wir
erinnern uns an das was uns wichtig ist
was uns gleichgültig ist
vergessen wir gleichgültigkeit führt
buchstäblich auf direktem weg in die
arme sie aber interessant daran ist doch
gerade dass man auch im fernsehen zb
immer wieder sagt menschen interessieren
sich für menschen menschen interessieren
sich und erinnern sich an geschichten
was stimmt bestimmt aber gerade auch aus
philosophischer perspektive die sich oft
wir interessieren uns doch auch für
argumente argumente und geschichten sind
zwei sehr interessante und
unterschiedliche ansätze kinder beginnen
schon sehr früh mit dem erzählen von
geschichten schon mit drei sind sie
fähig etwas wie eine geschichte zu
erzählen
mit einem anfang einen mittelteil und
einem ende
unsere soziale existenz beruht
weitgehend auf geschichten geschichten
lassen immer teile des lebens aus sie
sind ein verbindender mechanismus wenn
sie so wollen
niemand könnte über die wahrnehmbare
realität von ihnen und mir gerade jetzt
berichten und dabei jedes detail
erfassen
das ist unmöglich geschichten sind eine
methode um unsere existenz zu
organisieren
ein argument hingegen ist etwas anderes
es ist eine schritt-für-schritt bewegung
hin zu einem beweis
ich mag die form des ist
was vom französischen wort sed versuchen
abgeleitet ist weil es viel flexibilität
beinhaltet mich irritiert es in der
regel wenn alle wege zu gesperrt werden
ich nehme gerne eine fragestellung
beleuchtete sie aus verschiedenen
perspektiven und kreiere was ich
fokussierte zonen von mehrdeutigkeit
nenne das heißt wenn sie ein problem mit
verschiedenen theoretischen modellen
angehen erhalten sie unterschiedliche
antworten
das führt aber nicht zu einem brei oder
matsch vielmehr finden sie so
fokussierte methoden ein problem zu
betrachten welche sie zu einer neuen
guten frage führen können das ist
möglicherweise der eigentliche kern
intellektueller ideen des
intellektuellen lebens für mich
zumindest ist es besteht ja
wahrscheinlich auch darin dass wir zwar
alle wissen wahrheit ist vielschichtig
wahrheit ist mutig perspektivisch und
trotzdem hätten wir gerne die eine
wahrheit
das ist natürlich eine der ganz großen
fragen der philosophie und weil ich für
verschiedene quellen offen bin habe ich
sowohl viel kontinentaleuropäische
philosophie gelesen wie auch
angloamerikanisch analytische
philosophie in letzterer gibt es diese
eindeutige korrespondenz theorie der
wahrheit
die besagt dass es wahrheit gibt dem
mittels richtigen und falschen aussagen
überprüft werden kann
das ist natürlich sehr weit weg von der
phänomenologie und den post modernen
bedenken zum beispiel in den
französischen theorien der 1960 er 70er
und 80er jahre
wenn es um die wahrheitsfrage geht's
haben wir eine echte spaltung
bis zu welchem grad kann man wahrheit
überprüfen
viele post modernisten vergessen dabei
dass ist theoretischer modelle gibt zb
in der physik die sehr erfolgreich waren
quantenmechanik diese eigenartige
theorie in der wellen und partikel
koexistieren hat funktioniert wir wissen
dass dieses modell einen wichtigen
einfluss hatte zum beispiel auf laser
wir leben in einer welt in der die
technologie durch die quantenmechanik
beeinflusst worden ist
das geht in dieser x-beliebigen theorie
dass es keine wahrheit gebe oft
vergessen meine unterscheidung ist
wichtig weil es nicht einmal in der
physik eine theorie von allem gibt
niemand kann einsteins allgemeiner
relativitätstheorie mit der
quantenmechanik unter einen hut bringen
da ist eine kluft nicht einmal in der
physik gibt es also eine ultimative
wahrheit
entscheidend ist das modell wichtig ist
sich einzugestehen dass dieser
mathematischen modelle auch wenn sie
funktionieren
das subjektive menschliche bewusstsein
nicht erklären können
für die philosophie und die wissenschaft
bleibt es ein geheimnis
was ist das bewusstsein genau was sie
was ist das bewusstsein aber ich habe
jetzt auch über die physik gesprochen
und tatsächlich ist es ja so dass es
kein modell in der physik gibt das alles
erklärt und es bleibt eben bei modellen
und schlussendlich hat man eben die sind
eindruck dass die wahrheit immer
zerfällt in unterschiedliche facetten je
nachdem welches modell man anwendet und
trotzdem frage ich mich dann aber warum
haben wir diese sehnsucht alles unter
das eine modell zu packen wissen einen
standpunkt zu finden weil sie haben
die postmoderne erwähnt das hat ja auch
etwas sehr entspannen dass die
vorstellungen wie alle können viele sein
es gibt halt in jeder person multiple
persönlichkeiten vielleicht wird
zerfallen eigentlich in unterschiedliche
facetten hat auch was schönes
warum suchen wir diese einen das ist
eine tiefschürfend und wichtige frage
viele von uns leben in ihrem alltag als
würde die korrespondenz theorie der
wahrheit funktionieren gibt es zitronen
im kühlschrank
sie gehen und öffnen den kühlschrank und
sehen dass es welche gibt viele von uns
leben ein sehr geerdet es leben
wir akzeptieren die wahrheit der welt um
uns wir akzeptieren dass die anderen
menschen real sind
ich zweifle nicht daran dass sie mir
gerade jetzt gegenüber sitzen
ich frage mich nicht ob ich träume
obschon ich weiß dass es momente gibt in
denen ich träume und nicht weiß dass ich
träume und ich wache auf und entdeckte
dass dies nicht real war und wir haben
alle die momente in unserem leben die ja
zb sagt reh so schön beschrieben hat wo
wir mitten auf der straße stehen
plötzlich denken die ganze welt stürzt
ein das kann doch alles überhaupt nicht
die wahrheit sein was eigentlich ist
realität
darüber habe ich kürzlich mit einem
professor an der universität augsburg
gesprochen
robert schopf ein freund von mir er
erwähnte dass adorno einmal gesagt habe
dass philosophen und kinder sehr
ähnliche fragen stellten
ich finde das stimmt vielleicht ist das
schönste an der philosophie oder besser
gesagt an den philosophien dass sie
fortfahren die gleichen fragen zu
stellen die kinder ist die welt real was
ist da draußen bin ich jemand im traum
einer anderen person im traum wieder
einer anderen person im traum einer
anderen person ad infinitum
die kinder haben solche fantasien und
sie haben solche fragen und philosophen
sind menschen die nicht aufgeben diese
fragen zu stellen
das ist wundervoll gehen wir zurück zu
eigentlich dem thema heute auch der
geschlechter tanzte geschlechterkampf
natürlich wenn man über sie spricht
spricht man irgendwann immer auch über
paulustor ihren ehemann darüber wie sie
als paar miteinander eine glamouröse
führen die kommt immer irgendwo vor und
ein stück weit hieß es ja immer auch
dass sie darunter gelitten hätten oder
mit der hypothek zu leben hätten dass
sie nur die ehefrau von paul auster sein
jetzt steht in allen kritiken sie ihre
höchstwert beginnt polster den rang
abzulaufen
freut sie das oder finden sich das ja
peinlich wenn wir auf die frage des
blickwinkels zurückkommen wird es
interessant von innen her gesehen hat
das alles nichts zu tun mit dem
wirklichen leben wenn sie so wollen
mich verbindet eine lange freundschaft
und ehe mit einem menschen für mich eine
extrem interessante geschichte aber
diese von außen aufgedrückte version ist
dumm
ich finde sie langweilig und die idee
dass wir in einem konkurrenzkampf stehen
ist unglaublich dumm aber natürlich
interessieren sich die leute für ihre
beziehung
das ist ein stück weit wahrscheinlich
immer so weil sie so glamourös
erscheinen
schauen wir uns an was paul auster über
sie und über ihre beziehung sagt in aus
dem gleichen filmporträt über sich
ich bin froh dass wir zusammen sind
lehrlinge zusammen sind desto weniger
kann ich mir vorstellen nicht mit hier
zusammen zu sein
je älter man wird desto mehr ist man auf
seinen partner angewiesen
das ist erstaunlich wir brauchen uns
beide sehr
zum glück ist noch keiner von uns krank
so alt sind wir auch noch nicht
ich bin auf jeden fall noch meine enkel
erleben das würde ich liebend gern noch
nichts meine tochter arbeitet hart an
ihrer musik wir werden sehen was kommt
bestimmt wäre das ein weiteres abenteuer
in meinem leben auch nicht fasziniert
wenn ich diese bilder sehe wenn ich sie
sehe und wenn man immer wieder liest
eben ihr glamouröses leben zu zweit eine
intellektuelle nähe das ist immer etwas
was fasziniert von dem was an seinen
intellektuellen paar gleichzeitig in
ihrem werk hatte ich immer wieder den
eindruck sind die liebesbeziehungen
eigentlich selten glückliche beziehungen
es sind oft beziehungen wo sich die
[ __ ] sie einander an einen aneinander
reiben die frauen ergeben sich zum teil
auch in gefahr wenn sie männern nahe
kommen sie können an ihnen verzweifeln
denken wir an die figur der lilienthal
die unsichtbare frau auch was ich liebte
es sind schwierige liebesbeziehungen
warum schildern sie die
liebesbeziehungen oft als schwierige
beziehung während dessen sie offenbar
eine sehr sehr glückliche ehe
noch einmal es ist sehr gefährlich
kunstschaffen auf biografie zu
reduzieren
das ist eine sehr schlechte strategie
was mich reizte war ein buch über männer
freundschaft zu schreiben
nebst allem anderen die story handelt
von einem mann der eine lange geschichte
über zwei familien erzählt aber auch von
einer großen freundschaft zu einem
künstler den er sehr bewundert und die
gleißende welt hat 20 ausgeprägte
charaktere unter zähler
man muss wirklich auswählen eric burdon
verliert ihren mann findet dann aber
einen liebhaber bruno kleinfeld nun
liegt sie bruno was aber nicht der
mittelpunkt ihres lebens ist im zentrum
steht ihr ehrgeiz für ihre eigene kunst
in diesem sinn in bruno in harriets
leben nicht den ersten platz ein
er ist nebensächlich in meinen büchern
gibt es viele unterschiedliche
liebesgeschichten
manche davon sind mitgefahren verknüpft
und seien wir ehrlich in unserer kultur
sind frauen nach wie vor verletzlicher
als männer
lange ging eine frau nicht ohne
begleitung auf die straße während des
ganzen neunzehnten jahrhunderts mussten
frauen überall hin begleitet werden oder
sie waren prostituierte
es gibt immer noch gewalt gegen frauen
praktisch überall gibt es enormen
frauenhass in unterschiedlichem ausmaß
sowohl in europa wie in amerika denkt
sie aber auch an den nahen osten oder
anderswo denken sie an die beschneidung
von frauen in afrika
das sind sehr handgreifliche bedrohungen
eine bedrohung die man soziologisch
vielleicht auch erklären könnte ist dass
man ja oft sagt frauen werden auf ihr
äußeres reduziert
sie haben an verschiedenen stellen auch
gesagt bei hillary clinton spricht man
übers dekolleté berlin über ihren
hintern
das geht weiter ich bringe gerne dieses
beispiel es ist ein fiktionales beispiel
zwei personen beobachten auf einer party
eine wunderschöne junge frau am anderen
ende des raumes
es ist anfangs 30 sehr gut gekleidet mit
einem glas champagner sie lacht der eine
schaut in anderen an
es können zwei männer zwei frauen oder
ein mann und eine frau seien und sie
sagen
glaubst du wirklich dass diese schöne
frau dort drüben an ihrem zweiten post
doc in molekularbiologie an der
rockefeller university arbeitet so
funktioniert unsere erwartungshaltung
was ich so interessant finde ist dass
selbst diejenigen personen die ihr buch
präsentiert haben und darüber
geschrieben haben wie diese vorurteile
überall sind beginnen oftmals interviews
oder rezensionen damit wie schön sie
sind sie beginnen damit zu beschreiben
wie planen sie sind wie blaue augen sie
haben wie lange beine und so weiter
das würde man ja nicht tun bei einem
mann
das verfolgt frauen durchs leben wie sie
sagt ich war entsetzt darüber wie viel
aufheben gemacht wurde um einen schatten
in hillary clintons dekolleté der in
einigen fernsehbildern zu sehen war
wir müssen diese besessenheit was das
weibliche erscheinungsbild in unseren
kulturen betrifft hinterfragen wie sie
sagen
bei männern gibt es keine solchen
bewertungen des auftretens wir müssen
uns fragen was das bedeutet warum wir
das tun
beide tunnels frauen und männer wollen
wir das wollen wir wirklich menschen auf
diese äußerlichkeiten reduzieren
es ist ein verhalten das menschlichen
geschöpfen ihre innere subjektivität
ihre innere realität und ihre innere
komplexität abspricht
wir müssen begreifen dass das eine form
von grausamkeit ist es geht aber auch
wieder eigentlich zurück zu ihrer idee
die ich vorhin präsentiert haben nämlich
dass frauen auf die natur reduziert
während währenddessen man die männer auf
den intellekt eigentlich reduziert da
habe ich mich gefragt zuweilen
diskutiert man aber auch über die
muskeln von obama ihr tut
ich habe das noch nie gesehen ok ich
finde übrigens unser präsident obama ist
ein sehr gut aussehen der typ ich werde
das prüfen
ja manchmal diskutieren wir über die
schönheit von männern vor allem bei
filmschauspielern
interessant ist ja auch was man
überhaupt öffentlich macht man spricht
über körper öffentlichen und spricht
auch über gefühle öffentlich
mich hat bewegt dass sie sie haben ja
vorhin selber erwähnt dieses buch
eigentlich ein stück weit auch
anlässlich des todes ihres vaters
geschrieben haben und auch hier mann
paul auster hat das winter journal
geschrieben das den tod seiner mutter
glaube ich verarbeitet und in den
letzten wochen hat man hierzulande ich
glaube in der ganzen welt sehr oft
darüber diskutiert dass sheryl sandberg
die chefin von facebook einen post
publiziert hat 30 tage nach der
beerdigung ihres mannes der bei einem
sehr sehr tragischen unglück ums leben
kam
und darin schreibt sie sehr sehr
emotional darüber wie sehr ihr mann ihr
fehlt inwiefern sprechen wir heute
öffentlicher über unsere gefühle und was
macht das mit unseren gefühlen
jeder mensch ist ein emotionales gefühls
defizite sind krankhaft
es gibt zum beispiel menschen mit
gewissen formen von hirnschäden die
nicht in der lage sind große anteilnahme
für andere oder für sich selber zu
empfinden und auch die psychopathen mit
dieser eigenartigen
persönlichkeitsstörung bekannt aus der
psychiatrie die unfähig macht für die
zukunft zu planen und das eigene handeln
zu bestimmen
diese kälte ist eine krankheit jeder
braucht gefühle wenn sie keine gefühle
haben können sie in diesem leben nicht
bestehen und die festlegung von gefühl
als weibliche angelegenheit ist absurd
die idee dass frauen emotionaler sein
als männer was immer das heißt
ich glaube nicht dass das stimmt aber
die öffentlichmachung warum sollten wir
es eigenartig finden wenn jemand nach
dem verlust seines ehepartners oder
sonst eines geliebten menschen gefühle
zeigt william james schreibt in seinem
werk über psychologie im kapitel über
das selbst von jenem wichtigen teil des
selbst das mit anderen menschen
verbunden ist
er sagt wenn wir jemanden verlieren zb
ehefrau oder kinder geht ein teil des
selbst ebenfalls verloren
ich denke wir sind kreaturen säugetiere
organismen die sich mit anderen
verbinden
wenn wir das nicht tun wachsen wir nicht
zur normalen menschen hören
noch einmal das gehört zum menschen
wir müssen es akzeptieren dazu gehören
auch die gefühle unterschiedliche kultur
umgehen unterschiedlich damit um
es gibt kulturen mit professionellen
klage frauen die angestellt werden um an
der beerdigung laut zu weinen
in skandinavien zum beispiel in der
norwegischen kultur wird erwartet dass
man ruhig bleibt man darauf seine
gefühle nicht zeigen
es ist in ordnung wenn man daheim hinter
verschlossene türen schreit aber an der
beerdigung sollen die augen trocken
bleiben
was ich interessant von wo ich danke
vielleicht interessierte dieses thema
auch ist dass es viele menschen gibt die
sagen wir werden vielleicht die
emotionale nähe zu anderen menschen
aufgeben zugunsten von nahezu maschinen
computern gibt untersuchungen dass in
japan viele junge männer eigentlich
lieber irgendwo ein computer heiraten
würde eine sexpuppe aus eine reale
person gleichzeitig kehren wir mehr
emotionen ins öffentliche teilen das
dann also diese öffentlich machen von
sheryl sandberg wurde innerhalb von
stunden 600.000 mal angeklickt 1100
pausen fach gelegt und geschert ist das
nicht ein phänomen
die technologie verändert sich und die
geräte die wir menschen benutzten
verändern uns wir interagieren laufend
mit unseren umgebungen
in der tat kann die klare trennung
zwischen subjekt und objekt die in
einigen philosophischen theorien
angelegt ist problematisch seien wir
interagieren immer die phantasie der
künstlichen intelligenz und ich betone
es ist eine fantasie seit den 1950 er
jahren haben entwickler von künstlicher
intelligenz immer wieder vorausgesagt
dass für ihn 20 30 40 50 jahren
androiden haben werden die den menschen
sehr ähnlich
[Musik]
mit emotionen wie fühlen was wir fühlen
das stimmt schlicht nicht und sie sind
so weit davon entfernt dies zu erreichen
das ist eine der großen kulturellen
enttäuschung
ich habe gerade ein buch beendet mit dem
titel die ihre führungen der gewissheit
in denen ich der künstlichen intelligenz
einen langen abschnitt widme ich will
die tatsache dass sich big data und
technologischer fortschritt sehr schnell
entwickelt haben nicht bestreiten
das ist jedoch ein anderer blickwinkel
es geht um eine art von intelligenz die
auf einem digitalen modell auf bord
damit hat es sich
man ist weit davon entfernt echte
gefühle zu reproduzieren
sie zitieren an einer stelle louis
bursch war die gesagt hat kunst ist
nicht über kunst oder handelt nicht von
kunst sondern handelt vom leben ihr werk
sie registriert zeigt dass
wahrscheinlich an alle eindringlichsten
vielen dank für dieses gespräch
in der kunst geht es also ums leben und
oft auch um gesellschaftskritik einer
der kunst wie wenig andere dazu nutzt
gegen unterdrückung zu rebellieren ist
der chinesische künstler ai wei wei
sternstunde kunst zeigt jetzt gleich ein
porträt des streitbaren künstler
sie ist als neuester roman wird übrigens
auch im nächsten literaturclub
besprochen
am kommenden dienstag abend auf sf 1
grund genug also wieder zuzuschalten
oder jetzt gleich traum zu bleiben und
so oder so einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]